e
mes fils et christophe bosseur
c'est un gros boulot fait il n'est
jamais fatigué
très consciencieux exigeant avec lui
même
je m'appelle d'un mois parle d'un g14 me
et si on est au gymnase de luigi collège
hm-honda parce que j'ai fait de la lutte
du scios entre formateurs ou 2 saint
joseph bonjour moi oui ça va vraiment un
il est venu à saint joseph c'est chez
moi allaient augmenter alors voilà je
vous présente ma petite famille ma mère
bonjour oui nasser et johnny mon papa
imaginez pas qu'il allait aller eux
aussi loin dans ce sport quoi notre it
est un sport qu'elle allait pratiquer le
mercredi après midi le samedi comme ça
oui juste en soi loisirs j'ai dit non
non non pas question de toute façon tu
commences juste le collège je veux pas à
temps et bon début ma mère elle a eu un
peu peur parce que la lutte ou sahel
harper que ça m'inquiétait un peu mais
vous avez mal essayé et avec le temps
c'est mon salon or voilà ma chambre au
pouvoir qu il ya quelques posters que
j'ai ramené de france ça c'était quand
je suis parti bien pour ma première
année en france voir la france qui défie
l'allemagne au cirque d'hiver
après ça c'est des groupes aussi j'ai
connu ce jour-là wibert qu'aux débats
les grands athlètes de la lutte de la
lutte française ce sont les luthiers de
l'insep où je crois qu'un jour tu seras
là j'espère os cassés c'est mon ambition
ouah alors j'ai essayé des cahiers là
tout devient range des ordres avait
cantonné quand on est dans le centre
martyrs et tout ça il faut pas il faut
faut être bien organisé parce que si à
toi désordre et tout ça avec les
entraînements et tout ça on n'a pas
toujours forcément le temps lors
mais tant qu'on s'y retrouve et tout
faut vraiment été bien organisé pour
pouvoir eux tout pouvoir tout cas les
d'un coup vite fait bien fait voilà
comment ce par celle là ça c'est la
médaille que j'ai fait
dernièrement à la médaille de la
médaille de vice champion de france aux
championnats de france de lutte libre
si la médaille de vice champion de
france mais cette fois en lutte
c'était juste avant mois de janvier
cette fois en lutte gréco romaine de
styles différents une lutte surtout
besoin de lui et voilà ça fait j'ai
commencé en 5e la lutte trois ans ouais
ça fait trois ans là ça fait pas ça fait
beaucoup derrière trois ans ben ouais
c'est ouais c'est quand même pas mal
le déclic c'est et quand on a commencé à
nous dire que
tu n'étais pas mauvais quoi donc qu'il
avait des qualités et donc
mais après ça fait toujours plaisir
quand on dit que vos enfants c'est
débrouille bien qu'ils sont bien qu'ils
sont
qu'ils peuvent pratiquer les sports en
ayant des bons résultats de twitter oui
polenzani à la lutte à la rentrée
septembre route de l'année dernière way
et avec l'engouement de
qui a dans la famille disons que mais il
ya quatre ans il ya quatre ans avait
même pas ce que c'est qui est que c
était de la vue et c'est vrai que c'est
magnifique quoi donc se bonifie de vivre
ça en fait on a des emplois du temps de
fou parce que en fait on est pris à peu
le scolaire de la journée le travail
peut nous le soir on se retrouve sur les
tapis que soit entre parents qu'on fait
un foot avec les enfants se retrouvent
avec les parents les enfants et il doit
par beaucoup de deux familles comme ça
donc on apprécie à sa juste valeur
voilà mon collège c'est parti
au niveau scolaire donc ça va donner un
coup de corne oui ça va stimuler en fait
stimulé la possible hausse oui vous
serez très bien pas de travail
là je suis lâche rien même s'il n'a pas
compris le fond il ya un exercice à
devoir il va il va bosser jusqu'à ce
qu'ils comprennent
mais dans le gymnase du collège
secondaire où je passe une grande partie
de mon temps
d'ici là a sonné les jeunes devront
passer des tests pour intégrer le centre
aura t elle à tous des plus jeunes ben
si vous passez les gêner voilà pour les
groupes
quant au final minutes après il ya en
fait pas de la lutte que pour rester là
après il ya un débouché ou fini par
avouer à atteindre un point à niveau et
du coup j'ai touché tous envie de monter
un haut niveau de gravir les échelons
pour aller au plus haut niveau
rageant tout il ya tout ce qui tout ce
qu'ils sont et qui se met en place d'un
contrat avec les entraînements et tout
le chili des cours et tout ça et après
ça s'accélérer encore pouces avec
l'entrée au centre fort marqueur va pas
se contenter des entraînements de voir
la technique qui se réaliser
j'ai gagné j'ai perdu pour connaître les
jeunes n'est plus possible pour l'aider
à aider à progresser il faut tirer sur
les bonnes ficelles pour faire
progresser tel ou tel gars 1 1 1 qui sur
lequel il faut agir au côté émotionnel
d'autres cette rue côté physique l'autre
côté technique nous on essaie vraiment
en effet réfléchir sur pour qu elle
gagne quoi je perds j'ai réussi comment
faire pour réussir à tout le monde
pourquoi j'ai perdu l'un réfléchir sur
ce qu'ils font tous les rendre le plus
possible responsable et autonome et à
notre avis si le gamin et est capable et
capables de faire un match sans nous
c'est gagné
à
cantonné sur les tapis et ça révèle une
partie de ta personnalité du coup comme
on voit tout une voix presque toujours
sur les quartiers tout ça ils savent
comme on est alors nous font ces sacs et
qui donne confiance en qui donne
confiance afin qu ils aient gringue à
les brûler comme ça ça empêche pas
d'avoir un colis son physique
assez exceptionnel il a passé les tests
de recrutement à font romeu il a fini
premier au niveau physique bon on leur
fait faire des courses de montagne piton
des neiges vaut le montant 2h15 ses
premiers arriveront ils à il arriva il a
une capacité à gérer ses efforts une
lucidité danser dans les matchs alors
qu'il ya beaucoup de pression
très fier franchement auto pas parce que
c'est
c'est formidable ce qu'il a fait surtout
que lui avant les deux super tir idée
tout y est ils étaient vraiment très
réservée et la faire tout ça d'un coup
c'est ferait un formidable là d'une
baisse et que je vais entamer un taux de
jeu bientôt alors attendu lui aussi
quelque chose d'extraordinaire on n'a
pas l'occasion de faire ça chez toi mon
gars je n'ai pas l'occasion de faire ça
souvent alors ouais c'est quelque chose
de super pour la prochaine rentrée je
vais intégrer le pôle espoir de
fourneaux alors eh ben si tu as acheté
le moment mon but c'est de grimper les
échelons comme je dis alors là des
chopes jouer la technopole espoir ou
suite montant pôle france et j'étais
intégraux 2007
pas de limites c'est calme c'est tout
seul mais il allait mais c'est tout ça
et c'est la façon je peux rien faire et
les inquiète alors que moi tu loges que
tu le laisse sécher les laisse partir
parce que ben est comme ça et je vous
rattachez tour et sa réponse est
il fait tout pour avancer donc je ne
juge pas l'empêcher
qu'ils continuent à faire plaisir ça
marche pas si sûr plaisir
s'il ya la contrainte et arrière ainsi
que possible même si ça fait mal je
pense que j'ai tellement envie que je
réussisse dans ce que j'ai envie de
faire alors nous pousser le plus loin
possible